الكولونيل لايتون ، دعونا ننظر إلى هذا
البالون الذي يبلغ عنه أورين
حجم ثلاث حافلات ، وهذا ضخم
حيث يشير أورين إلى أن الصين لديها أقمار صناعية
تشاهد الولايات المتحدة طوال
الوقت ، فما هذا الشيء حول
ما تفعله الصين هنا؟
أحد الأشياء الكبيرة التي
يمكن أن تفعلها الصين مع آرون هو أنه
يمكنهم جمع معلومات
استخباراتية بمعنى آخر أنهم
ينظرون إلى حركة مرور الهاتف الخلوي لدينا وهم ينظرون
إلى حركة الاتصالات اللاسلكية لدينا ، وهم
ينظرون إلى شبكات القيادة والسيطرة الحكومية
أه وكما أشار أورين
أه لدينا سلسلة أساس صواريخ باليستية
من صوامع الصواريخ الباليستية في
مونتانا وفي نورث داكوتا ووايومنغ
أه ، فهذه هي الأشياء التي
يمكن أن ينظروا إليها أيضًا أه هم على
الأرجح ينظرون إلى الاستراتيجية
قواعد قاذفات القنابل التي لدينا في داكوتا ، لذلك
هذا شيء أه تعرف أنه
يمنحهم فرصة ربما لزيادة
تغطية الأقمار الصناعية الخاصة بهم وهو بالتأكيد
نظام يمكن أن يجمع الكثير
من البيانات ، وهذا ما تقوله هو
أن هناك  المزيد من البيانات
والبيانات المحددة تشير إلى الهواتف المحمولة الاستخباراتية
التي لن تكون قادرة على الحصول على
طرق أخرى يمكن أن يحصلوا عليها من هذا ،
ولمجرد توضيح النقطة التي
تتحدث عن أساس القاذفة الاستراتيجية هذا ،
أنا آسف أه المنشآت النووية
شوهد هذا فوق بيلينجز مونتانا
وكما يقول أورين لا يوجد الكثير من الناس
هناك وهذا جزء من سبب
كونهم مهمين من الناحية الإستراتيجية
للولايات المتحدة بالنسبة لترسانتنا النووية
وقاعدة القاذفات الإستراتيجية ، أعني أن
هذا الموقع ضخم  إنه أمر مهم
وأنت تعلم أنه جزء مما
نسميه ثالوثنا النووي المكون
من قاذفات صواريخ وغواصات ، لذا فإن
جزأين من هذا الثالوث موجودان
مباشرة في مسار هذا البالون الصيني ،
لذا
أعتقد أنني أشعر بالفضول  أعتقد أنه
يجب عليهم إسقاطه ، أعني أنه
يطفو هناك فقط ، أعني أنك تعلم
أن هذا سؤال حقيقي أنهم
قرروا عدم القيام بذلك في الوقت الحالي ،
ما رأيك في ذلك وأنا أعلم
أنك تعتقد أيضًا أن الصين قد  في
الواقع ، لا تفعل ذلك من أجل
نفسها فحسب ، بل من أجل بوتين ،
نعم أه في الواقع ، هناك
معلومات استخباراتية قوية للغاية تشارك العلاقة
بين الصين وروسيا ، لذا فإن أحد
الأشياء التي يجب عليك النظر إليها عندما
يتعلق الأمر بهذا هو نوع
الدبلوماسية  أه فياسكو سيكون الأمر إذا
أسقطته ، فأنت تعلم أن هناك
احتمالية أنه يمكن أن يزيد التوترات
أكثر أه هناك احتمال
بالطبع إذا قمت بإسقاطه كما
تعلم كما أوضحت لورين أه
سيكون هناك إمكانية  خسارة
الأرواح على الأرض أه ، فهذه
أشياء يجب موازنتها وإذا
اعتقدوا أنها يمكن أن تخفف من
جهود الجمع وإذا كان بإمكانهم جعلها بلا
معنى نسبيًا أو
غير ضارة نسبيًا ، فعندئذٍ يختارون عادةً السماح
لأشياء مثل هذه بالتحليق  مرارًا وتكرارًا ودعهم
ينتقلون إلى أه تعرفهم
إلى معالجيهم